folks we're going to have to meet you
today talk about the critical
supply chain
critical supply chain issues that will
affect us all
supply chain including the ppe that we
needed badly but had to go offline to
get
and uh there are current strategies of
these little
chips here for automobiles i didn't
realize how much
the chips are in here but uh
causing some lines to slow down and
people not being laid off but
at least the shortened ships and uh so
we're going to talk about that uh john
cornyn
and uh and the bipartisan group here
put together an effort last year that i
think is a pretty good effort dealing
with
how to deal with these chips but there's
other
aspects of shortages as well that's what
we're going to talk about
and uh it's nice to have everybody down
here and
uh we all agree on and figure out how we
uh
get it all done so thank you all for
coming on in and uh
i appreciate it thank you we're gonna
move
on
thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
thank you thank you so much
thank you thank you so much thank you
you said you'll have to ask them oh okay
he said what
i said do you think that these were
totally considered now